[Music]
this reconciliation of Consciousness
with self-consciousness thus shows
itself is brought about from two sides
on one side in the religious spirit and
on the other side in Consciousness
itself as such
the difference between them is that in
the former this reconciliation is in the
form of being in itself or implicit
being and in the latter in the explicit
form of being for self
in our consideration of them they at
first fall apart
in the other in which the shapes of
Consciousness came before us
Consciousness reached the individual
moments of those shapes and their
unification long before ever religion
gave its object the shape of actual
self-consciousness the unification of
the two sides has not yet been exhibited
it is this that closes the series of the
shapes of spirit for in its Spirit
attains to a knowledge of itself not
only as it is in itself or as possessing
an absolute content nor only as it is
for itself as a form devoid of content
or as the aspect of self-consciousness
but as it is both in essence and in
actuality or in and for itself
paragraph 794 is relatively short and it
seems pretty straightforward but there
is a lot going on here so we're going to
have to linger over this and unpack a
lot of things that aren't directly in
the paragraph but are being referenced
in very important ways I also do want to
Signal you know sometimes I will talk
about ah Miller you know his translation
here is a little bit shaky or he's
adding some stuff there is actually a
typo which is probably not
caused by Miller as far as we know the
translator of this particular Edition
but which could be very
misleading and cause readers to say wait
a second what's what's actually
happening here so in the discussion
um here we go this is about halfway
through in the other in which the shapes
of Consciousness came before us you
might be saying well what's that other
who's the other in this case is it does
this have to do somehow with
self-consciousness and it's other which
is another self-consciousness and so
that could lead you into a lot of let's
call it rabbit holery right where you're
you're going down into other passages
and saying what does Hegel mean here so
it's actually a typo it's not other it
should be another word that ends with
the and begins with the same letters
order
ordnung in German
so once that is said it really makes
this part about the series the uh
ordering of the shapes of Consciousness
fall into place for you right so we'll
get to that in a bit but I just wanted
to put that on everybody's radar in case
you're reading through this right
and then uh there's another thing
towards the very end where Miller you
know every once in a while Miller will
add his own glosses sometimes he's good
enough to do that in Brackets here he's
not doing that and he's adding in two
things that are I mean technically not
incorrect since they were referenced in
this paragraph and in the previous
paragraphs and it's typical hegelian
stuff but that are not actually being
said in the text by Hegel so we're it's
at the very end when he's talking about
um you know the aspect of
self-consciousness but as it is both in
essence and in actuality or in and for
itself
so what Hagel is actually saying is just
as it is uh V is in and for itself this
Essence and in essence and in actuality
um isn't there but you know it is it
there in the background yes I mean we
just talked about
actuality or vehicle kite on the side of
religion so there's something there
right and you know Essence being Vasan
can translate as either of those so yeah
that's that's not that big of a problem
so let's begin with the beginning of
this uh we've just referenced in uh the
previous paragraphs
reconciliation of things you know for
example 793 began with moments of which
the reconciliation of spirit with its
own Consciousness proper is is composed
right and so we've got a reference back
to that this reconciliation
of Consciousness but now it's not just
of Consciousness with spirit it's of
Consciousness with
self-consciousness now we should pause
on this for for just a moment and remind
ourselves of a few things
where have we seen this before the
opposition and productive engagement
with and then reconciliation of
Consciousness and self-consciousness
well the beginning of the religion
section was talking about that wasn't it
and we're going to see in the next
paragraph uh 795 more discussion of
unification which is one way in which
this reconciliation is taking place
unification reconciliation not exactly
the same right but one leads to the
other and we see a reference there to
religion doing this and how does
religion do this by taking what we call
picture thinking or representation for
stellon and pushing it to its ultimate
as far as it can go where it's going to
bleed over into something
going Beyond and sublating
representation okay so that's that's
good
um where else have we seen Consciousness
and self-consciousness needing to be
reconciled well we could say through the
whole self-consciousness section right
self-consciousness is consciousness of
course right but it's something that
transcends mere Consciousness because it
does involve the self and by involving
the self it also is related to an other
self-consciousness or as we're going to
find out not just and other but plural
others a whole world of other
self-consciousnesses and try to relate
itself to some sort of transcendent
objects some ideal this is what the
unhappy Consciousness which we could
also call the unhappy self-consciousness
is is all about and then we saw this
playing itself out in the later
dialectics as well in the much more
substantive sections of reason and
spirit so we've got a lot going on there
just in this first phrase in the uh
first sentence this reconciliation of
Consciousness with self-consciousness
thus shows itself it displays itself to
us the phenomenologist who is following
along with hegel's presentation so you
know we've got really three different
characters or perspectives working at
the same time we have what Consciousness
self-consciousness is doing with itself
uh understanding itself right which is
sort of the Triumph that we're going to
get to at the end of this then we have
Hegel the narrator the analyst the
synthesizer the also selector of what's
going to go into the work and what's not
um looking on and then we have because
of Hegel us the readers 200 years plus
and the the future are present reading
this alongside and seeing at least to
some extent what it is that Hegel
himself sees Spirit seeing right so
um
brought about by two sides now uh sides
zaita being used throughout there
um something that's kind of left out a
little bit or perhaps de-emphasized in
the translation godolph uh literally
doubled turned into two right and I I
like that term because it shows you that
we're not just talking about like ah
there's just two sides here and they
happen to you know fall apart like that
it's a process of doubling so the act of
working through this of progressing is
what is doubling it turning it into a
two-sided thing which is more real than
a one-sided thing right so we've got
this reconciliation this physunung of
Consciousness and self-consciousness it
has got two sides to it well what are
these two sides
so one of them is we would be tempted to
say one of them is religion and then the
other is consciousness but it's not
quite so simple as that
so he says on the one side
in
the religious
Spirit the religion geista right so this
is what the religion section is about
and it's what gets developed and
depicted in the religion section to be
sure but we're not saying that it is the
religion section it's in the religion
section right and that in I think is
quite important and then on the other
side we have
um
in Consciousness but
Consciousness itself
as such so you notice a double
intensifier there right
Consciousness itself not just any old
Consciousness what whatsoever
as such
so these are I say is the word
intensifiers but maybe we could actually
we want to make up a
neologism these are zero inners right we
are like zeroing in on Consciousness and
not just Consciousness as itself but
Consciousness itself in what is most
essential to it this is a good reason
why Miller could read in here
Essence a little bit later on
okay so far so good
right and you see that there's already a
ton of stuff going on just in this first
sentence so now he talks about the
difference between them
the difference between what well between
the sides the doubled sides of the
reconciliation the different ways of
looking at the reconciliation of
apprehending it the difference between
them is that in the former which is the
in the religious spirit the
reconciliation is in the form of being
in itself
or implicit being
you know very common locution we've seen
throughout Hegel we don't need to dwell
on that too much because where we're
going is actually going to be getting
past that and then on the other side in
the latter Consciousness itself as such
they are in the explicit form of being
for self and then he says okay in our
consideration of them they at first
fall apart so not only are the
perspectives doubled but the let's say
the metaphysics of what's going on here
is also split into two different sides
and you know we're not doing John Paul
start here who also makes extensive use
in being a nothingness of the being in
itself you know the beingness of the
world and perhaps of other things like
our bodies uh the things that we've done
and then being for itself which is a you
know a lack in the heart of being uh you
know there's nothingness in there and
that's what human being is and
Consciousness would be on that side as
well no hegel's going to bring them back
together and to do so in a let's say at
a substantive way right
so he goes on and he says in our
consideration of them they first fall
apart in the other the other in which
the shapes of Consciousness came before
us in the order right the ordnung in
which the shapes of Consciousness and
he's using this word shapes gestalts
over and over again this is very
familiar to all of you who've been
following along with Hegel up to this
point
um consciousness
Spirit progresses through taking on
particular shapes that at the time seem
very
Universal very general but they turn out
to be uh you know particular universals
within this vast progression that we
call the dialectic where we're moving
through the development of human
consciousness right so we've got shapes
of Consciousness and they have appeared
in an order well actually let's take a
pause here a little bit of a side or
digression
Hegel thinks that there's a necessity
behind
this this work the phenomenology of
spirit note vindicate it's not necessity
in the same sense of logical necessity
where you know we're doing deductive
reasoning and you can Venn diagram it or
truth table it or something like that
it's a more complex kind of necessity
these different shapes these different
stages each one had to come before the
other and then lead into something else
and we have some you know overarching we
could call them unities or progressions
the Consciousness section the
self-consciousness section the reason
section the spirit section and then of
course the religion section which we've
come through which is represented by the
religious spirit
so the ordinong the order is it really
as absolutely necessary as Hegel uh
thinks it is as he thinks he's
discovered within history I mean that's
really debatable
um and I think we have to be a little
bit skeptical of that but also generous
towards Hegel and following along
instead of saying oh you know this this
proves the whole system because you know
it didn't turn out exactly the way that
we thought or there's more going on in
this thing or this thing and I I don't
think that's what we want to do if we
actually want to learn from Hegel but we
shouldn't follow him slavishly either I
mean that would be kind of contrary to
the nature of spirit wouldn't it we
don't want to say oh well the Great
Master has figured everything out and we
just need to like conform ourselves to
his mindset I think we want something
that's uh different from both of those
but that is a bit of an aside so let's
let's close that uh uh little ramble
into methodology and come back to this
so he says
in the order in which the shapes of
Consciousness came before us
Consciousness
reached the individual moments of those
shapes
now this is very interesting
and their unification their I need going
long before ever religion gave its
object the shape of actual
self-consciousness so there's a lot
going on there both in the language that
we need to look at but also in
implications so Consciousness the
Consciousness itself reached the
individual moments of those shapes and
their unification this is two different
things
each of those shapes of Consciousness
going throughout all of these uh the
phenomenologist the person studying has
reached the meaning the essence of those
that's part of what the process of auf
habong involves right it's sort of like
a separating out the wheat from the
chaff if you don't know about that
metaphor which is used heavily in the
gospels and then subsequently by all
sorts of secular authors the wheat is
what you actually want you're going to
eat it the chaff is the extra stuff
that's fiber less digestible we call
that bran and you know there's also you
know like the straw and things like that
that may have crept in and when we uh
engage in alphaben or alphabung as we do
throughout the hegelian dialectic and as
human beings do throughout history
that's why there can be a dialectic in
the first place we are leaving behind
some stuff and we are appropriating and
carrying forward and perhaps even
transforming what is essential the Vasan
right or vasen height
so that is what Consciousness has been
doing with all of these shapes but
notice he also says their unification
and then there's this temporal thing
long before ever religion gave its
object the shape of self-consciousness
so that's an interesting thing to say
maybe even a weird thing to say maybe
even if you've been reading through the
phenomenology a counter-intuitive thing
to say because yes the religion section
and spirit is conscious of itself
through religion
as narrated by Hegel is coming
second to last true but it's not like
religion
hasn't been around as long as human
history and perhaps even before it if
we're talking about you know written
history actually not perhaps definitely
the case
so what does Hegel actually mean in
saying this to us
it's not that temporally
religion and the unification or giving
its object the shape of
self-consciousness
um
that religion you know came very late on
the scene
no no it's been there but it hasn't
always been
conscious of itself as
self-consciousness
in religion Hegel thinks this comes
later on
but even with that you know we could say
you know so long as there's interiority
subjectivity on the part of religious
people then we have some sort of
um you know dynamic going on there that
we have to attend to and what would that
Dynamic actually include or exemplify I
think about Saint Augustine right a late
ancient writer who definitely I mean
some people actually say he's the
inventor of interiority which we know
can't possibly be the case that's not
true at all
but
um you know he's pretty early and a lot
of the things happening in the reason
and spirit section are happening quite a
bit later and we could also say well
wait a second what about
self-consciousness in religion in the
unhappy Consciousness in the
self-consciousness section so that can't
be what what hegel's saying here it must
be something more like you know this
unification is happening implicitly in
spirit and it's going to actually take
part uh through religion later on before
religion gave its object the shape the
Gestalt of actual Vehicles right so
here's actuality self-consciousness
so we've got a challenge here ahead of
us more than anything else
and he goes on and he starts talking
about this unification of the two
sides saying it's not been yet exhibited
but it is happening this unification
right or at least it seems to be in this
paragraph seems to be in the absolute
knowing section and he goes on and he
says it is this what is this being
exhibited by spirit that closes the
series of the shapes of spirit so we've
got Raya you know series row literally
and ordering ordering seems to be a
little bit more complex
and here he uses another term that isn't
radically different but it's worth
noting the difference
the series of the shapes of spirit the
Gestalt gestalten no Gestalt Des
geisters
what's the difference there
well it's it's kind of tough to say is
he just using it as a synonym I mean
Hegel is not that enterprising of a
writer I would say so you know the
gestation
is the the series of that
I think what we can read in here and
this is just one of you know POS many
possible interpretations but I'll give
it to you
the
ordering the intensification the
connection
of these shapes
right we've got gestaltin gestaltingen
gestaltongan right and now notice that
that's plural too
right so it's happened in these big
sections and perhaps we could say even
in their subsections where we see an
important shift like when we go from the
first part of self-consciousness to all
this stuff about stoicism skepticism and
the unhappy Consciousness and you're
like why are you going in that direction
you know so all of these things
are important here and by seeing the
connection throughout this entire work
and the progression of each of these
shapes of Consciousness this is how the
unification of Consciousness itself as
such and the religious spirit
through the two sides of this
reconciliation this is how that is
taking place
that's a lot to wrap your head around so
you might want to go through that kind
of slowly and he says that this closes
the series of the shapes of spirit in it
Spirit attains to a knowledge of itself
well you know Spirit has been attaining
to knowledge of itself at many different
points but this is like we're getting
close to the very final uh configuration
understanding itself knowledge of itself
in the greatest sense and what is this
knowledge of itself he says not only as
it is in itself or as possessing an
absolute content
typical there right you know it
understands its content in all of these
these shapes
but also as it is as he says for itself
and here he brings up a co-relative to
content uh as the aspect of
self-consciousness right uh as it is for
itself as a form devoid of content so
we've got once again we come back to
Consciousness self-consciousness
Consciousness is content in health
self-consciousness is form lacking
content but able to take in the content
right and part of that content is the
content of who it is and what it is in
relation to other self-consciousnesses
but also in relation
to whatever it is that is most essential
the Divine the Eternal uh as we find out
later well earlier from where we are but
later in the religion section the
community
as such articulated structured through
representations that it participates
within so this leads to this unification
and where do we get to in the end well
as he says
as it is and here's the Miller both in
essence and in actuality or
in and for itself and you know this is
typical Hegel Jive right we want to get
away from just the in itself or the four
itself and have something that's in and
for itself but this is where we're
actually like getting close to having it
we're you know just we're not uh uh uh
we're about
a little bit more than 10 and we're
closer to 14 paragraphs yet to go in
this 808 paragraphs in the whole work
right so the in and for itself that
we're getting here you could say is a
closer to the truly in and for itself
that is us
spirit
us not as individuals but as connected
with each other through the great
mediator this guy Hegel and the work
that he has put forth for us to learn
from and make our way through and have
our Consciousness transformed and
conformed in the process so you see
there's a ton of stuff being folded in
here in just this you know short set of
lines that comprise this particular
paragraph